thrilled to have back here on the Rich
Eisen show as always for Turner Sports
Ernie Johnson how are you Ernie I'm
wonderful rich how are you how great is
this tournament been man it's tremendous
we love it every year when we get to do
that this is you know how many years
we've been doing the tournament now with
CBS the eighth year which is gone by in
a blink and it just gets it gets better
and more fun every year and gets more
unpredictable and man this has been you
know when you see to 911 winning not in
the first round but in the sweet 16 that
just it just paints the picture of how
how totally unpredictable this whole
thing has been I do by the way in my
bracket yes have have Michigan in there
in the final four okay
taking on who did you think it was
coming out of the South Virginia you
know I had Arizona I had originally I
had Virginia winning the whole thing and
they had the injury to hunter and I said
that's gonna catch up to him at some
point I didn't think it would catch up
to him against the retrievers but no I
had Arizona there but I mean everybody
everybody's young and that in that
region the region of doom I know do you
taking out Arizona and taking out
Virginia and putting in Arizona you were
just rearranging deck chairs in the
Southtown
ridiculous just and and here's the thing
when the tournament started I got my
first 12 games right
so I'm sitting here I'm saying this
might be this might be all year I'm 12
and oh and then I lost three of the next
four that Thursday night and I was like
it was it was all down he could only
frozen time yeah I do remember it was
chalk right there was it was I saw that
stats 11 and 1 was essentially was the
where the the top seeds in the first 12
games I saw that stat early on let's not
dwell on my bracket please well I guess
before we get before we get to the
tournament here I do want to talk about
this election show Ernie because there
was a lot of criticism about it I
actually
I actually liked you get into the meat
of who's in and who's out first cuz I
could never tell whose bubble was popped
just by merely having the brackets
revealed III am wondering how that
criticism was received I think it's
always received by who by I guess you by
you and the rest of the team there I
mean I mean I you know I think that
anytime you're going to tinker with
something like this election show you're
going to open yourself up to that and
that's not unexpected but I think it was
also a response you know to previous
years sometimes where it took too long
to get all the information out so I
think that was that was the the number
one thing is let let's get the teams out
there let's let everybody know who's in
there and and in the first 40 minutes of
the show we had everything out there we
had every bracket out there and we had
you know all 68 teams in the first you
know 15 minutes of the show so in terms
of that that's that's fine and then and
then if you don't like alphabetical
order okay that's you know here's the
thing
everybody's gonna listen to this and and
nobody's living in a in a bubble and
saying oh no that's perfect that can't
be changed no they the folks who put
that together always take into account
what the fan wants and so you know
that's you let everybody have their say
that's fine we expect that and then and
try to make the next one better than the
previous one and always try to get
always try to make the next one better
well I like I said I would never be able
to tell just by watching the brackets be
revealed in the old-style way whose
bubble burst until you just saw it on a
screen hey by the way now that you know
where the brackets are these are the
five teams that that didn't that didn't
get selected so and I'm not one of those
to be honest with you who was critical
of it and I've really enjoyed the
coverage immensely we have had Candice
Parker on yesterday I just love all the
different voices that you and Greg
Gumbel have been expertly mostly it's
been the two of you guys hosting and
then tonight you're on with Charles and
the rest of the crew in Atlanta
we're who's on tonight well actually
again we split it up in right in New
York is Greg Gumbel with Charles and
Kenny and okay and Clark and then I'm
down here with Seth Davis and Brendan
Haywood and Candace and Greg Marshall
from Wichita State so yeah no I
it's it's a very you know when you look
at it and if folks may not have any idea
how this all comes together and I and
and I shake my head sometimes wondering
how it all gets done because especially
in those first couple of days there were
so many shows on four networks
constantly and you're just told okay
you're doing halftime on truTV now okay
and then be ready to turn around and do
the between game show on CBS and then
after that you got halftime on TNT and
then you're gonna bring to see a TBS on
the air I mean it's it's that way
non-stop those two days so excessive now
that it slowed down a little bit us a
little more manageable and basically
they're handling the CBS games tonight
we're handled in the TBS games tonight
okay so on TBS tonight let's let's break
it down what do you think's going to
happen on the Turner Broadcasting System
all right our first game is Villanova
West Virginia and I would I would
hesitate to hesitate to go with a
favorite there but I will take Villanova
and then if they're they're playing so
well offensively and defensively and
although I
I think West Virginia's got the toughest
player in the in the tournament
I think Javon Carter is is as tough as
anybody out there and has a wonderful
will to get the Mountaineers there but I
just think Novus too much and our second
game on TBS is Purdue and Texas Tech and
so again that's you know if you're
looking for an upset tonight you know
that would be a three over a two if
Texas Tech were able to be Purdue but
you know it's the Texas Tech's just a
very in-your-face great hustle team and
you know knocked out Florida in their
last game and Purdue is behind the
situation with Isaac Haas and the elbow
we understand that he's got a brace on
that elbow now that has been approved
for play the
question now is whether Matt painter is
going to play him or not so Purdue in
Texas Texas second game and then and
then obviously the the regional final
and then the whole shootin match you're
gonna get the final four oh yes I mean
what for somebody seriously for somebody
who's been around Turner for as long as
you have Ernie what will it mean to have
the Final Four on TBS
well it'll be the second time and it's
going to be a tough you know it's going
to be a tough act to follow after what
we had in 2016 when the Villanova game
winner at the buzzer so but it's it's
just a it's such a cool event rich and I
and until I experienced that Saturday of
the Final Four I had no idea how great a
day that was I mean when you've got
you've got all these fan bases and all
these colors and all this College
enthusiasm in this one building and it's
just it's just dynamite so that's you
know we're looking forward to Saturday
and then of course the championship game
on Monday and who knows who's gonna be
in that thing at this point but you know
we could have sister Jean on the pregame
routine and Charles Barkley I would sign
for that right now yeah I've already
I've already looked and you know the
possibility of a you know you know
sister Jean and Charles on the Riverwalk
and you know and and eating churros and
and and would it would just be special
but hold on a minute now now I would
actually sign up if I may cross streams
of Turner coverages here sister Jean an
area 21 I would sign for that Wow Jean
would sign up for that no no no but what
she would be sort of a human anti curse
button right there would I think kg
would not need the cusp oh that's right
you know we're in the president mr. Jane
and and and we had we ran an interview
yesterday to with Eric Musselman
daughter Mariah that's right there's
eight years old interviewing the ninety
eight year old nun and it was just
delightful and so it it's just part of
the thing that just makes it such a
special few weeks of the year
aside from all the brackets and people
you know talking trash and pull it for
their teams and that kind of thing but
it's it's just a wonderful time and
we're just you know eight years in man
it's just it's been a it's been a
wonderful it's been a wonderful thing to
be part of and before I let you go on
Ernie to go on TBS tonight I would be
remiss if I did not mention that your
New York Times best seller unscripted
now available in paperback
congratulations on that Oh what should
people be looking for if they didn't
read the hardback know it's it's it's
basically it's the same it's the same
book but it's in paperback now and so
it's out there and it's at Amazon and
it's Barnes and Noble and wherever you
get your books and and thanks to all
those folks who read it and and and made
it a that was that was beyond any of my
wildest dreams that it would make the
New York Times list and it's it's been
it's been an awesome experience to watch
it and to hear from folks who have been
impacted in some way by it well I mean
nothing's more personal than a book and
you pour it all out there in these pages
Ernie it's it's terrific it really was
it was a wonderful experience to to have
had and it was it's been a it's been a
great year came out it came out the day
after the championship game a year ago
so we're kind of a year in so it's it's
been it's been wonderful I appreciate
you Ernie
you know I always loved having you on
the show I really enjoy watching you
we'll check back in as the Association
begins to cook with the winner go home
stuff
so almost playoff time man yeah we
finished this and turn right around and
jump into the NBA playoffs can't wait
and then opening day as next week -
uh-huh yeah and the Masters and I said
oh good stuff Ernie thanks again well
all right Richie
konban that the best Ernie Johnson the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience